Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
And today, we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you for joining us for our 14th episode!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
It's Friday!
I feel like Ruffians really like Fridays, right?
Friday!
Yeah.
Isn't there a saying?
Huh?
Friday.
Fluffy and Fuzzy Friday.
Is that it?
It's a bit difficult to say.
Maybe that's how it goes.
I don't know, the Ruffians seem... Happy Fluffy Fuzzy Friday.
The Ruffians seem to be extra... Nice.
Extra.
Energetic.
Smiley.
Extra kind today.
Silly, maybe a bit silly.
Thank you for all the gift submissions!
Thank you!
Let's BAU BAU!
Member Gift Friday.
Member Gift Friday?
To explain, we got off track.
For Ruffians joining us for the first time today, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, Monday.
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face, not Moco-chan's face.
Your face!
And start your day off on the right paw.
Ruffians, please make sure to tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING.
Let's all BAU BAU to FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Well, Ruffians, I guess maybe it's not too surprising.
Do you know what's gonna come next?
Well, there's been another Pero Sighting!
Wait, I see this one.
Here is... What do we have?
Oh, he's in the back!
It seems like Pero has spotted crashing a wedding and attempting to steal their...
Pon-de-ring wall?
Is this a normal thing at weddings?
Maybe it might be nice to get married if it means I can have a wall of pon-de-rings, you know?
Who cares about who you're marrying if I can eat a hundred?
No.
Two hundred and fifty pon-de-ring.
A hundred, I don't know.
But two hundred and fifty, yeah.
250 pon-de-rings for free.
Yeah, apparently that's what this Ruffian said.
There's over 250 pon-de-rings in attendance!
Wanderings in attendance.
Yeah, I can't really blame Pero for trying to crash the wedding and take the donuts, you know?
You know, hopefully he was bringing some for us though, right?
Not just gonna eat them all himself, right?
No!
I think he could probably store a lot inside of him, but he needs to share.
We're good at that.
He should share too.
He should share too, right?
Well, you know...
Ruffian, I think you did a very good job as the King of Donuts because you were able to keep Pero away!
BAU BAU BAU!
Congratulations!
But do you have any idea where he went afterwards?
That would be helpful, right Moco-chan?
He probably can't go far with phone rings inside, right?
Well, maybe he didn't get it.
Maybe he's just, I'm gonna go somewhere else.
Escape.
Escape, yeah.
Anyways, Ruffians, please let us know if you have any more sightings.
Remember to use the hashtag, FWMCMORNING, okay?
Okay!
BAU BAU!
We had some big news just the other day.
Ruffians, you know, we had... De-den!
Lifetime Showtime!
As part of our celebration of spending one month from our debut, we were able to premiere the video for our original introduction song, Lifetime Showtime!
You heard right!
You've been listening to it lots, right, Ruffians?
Yeah!
Lifetime Showtime!
You're still stuck in your head?
Perfect!
That's exactly how it should be.
Exactly.
You know, we're really so thrilled to finally be able to share it with you all like this.
We hope that we'll be able to do more with it in the future too.
And you know, have more opportunities in the future too.
Lifetime Showtime.
Maybe Ruffians, maybe someone don't know, but Lifetime Showtime was written by Suo Patra-san. She's a VTuber and a creator that we really really like and admire.
We were really so happy to be able to work with her!
It was a really fun process, right, Moco-chan?
It was so good!
We hope that, Ruffians, that maybe you'll treasure this song just as much as we do, and that it never leaves your head.
Make sure to listen more, okay?
So that it can get thoroughly...
Input it in your head.
Maybe in like the bloodstream too.
That deep.
Very deep.
Yeah, so you feel it in your bloody.
In the bawdy.
In the bowens.
The bowens?
Yeah.
Like deep in the bowens.
You know, it was actually a really big dream of ours to be able to debut with an original intro song.
So we're happy that it came true.
You know, you only ever debut once, so... We're lucky, right, Moco-chan?
Please, Ruffians, yell FUWAMOCO out while listening to it, okay?
Can we practice a bit?
Oh, that way Ruffians won't be so embarrassed.
Fuwa.
Moco.
Why is it like this?
Fuwa.
Mocoi.
Ruffians, you did it together with us, right?
That feels a bit more right.
Why did we start backwards?
Ruffians, don't forget, okay?
You can start backwards from your oshi, too.
Ai.
Maybe it changes things up a little bit.
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
FUWAMOCO!
And... You have a surprise.
Ruffians!
No!
It's your favorite part of the day!
Misunderstanding.
And... BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
We did it!
The second time in history!
Today there are no misunderstandings.
Gone windy.
No misunderstandings.
We're so happy.
Ruffians, let's let out a big BAU BAU together!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
Where are you?
No misunderstandings!
It's correct.
Correct, right?
Until Monday.
Don't say things like that, okay?
Ruffians are especially silly today.
Why are you acting like it's the end of the world?
Well, at least I'm hoping that there's not going to be any new misunderstandings.
Maybe we can make it days without misunderstandings too.
Yeah, you know we have our collab with Abyss and- I guess there will be more days.
I don't know if it's over the weekend.
We're playing with the park and everything, and Nerissa, and Shiori, and Biboo.
I don't know about them.
If we haven't had any misunderstandings since the last FUWAMOCO Morning, wouldn't it be more than just one day?
I don't want to think that hard about it, Moco-chan.
You know, this is good just as it is.
No misunderstanding.
No math.
This is how it is.
Yeah.
But, we actually have something that we want to share.
Something that we want to confess with the Ruffians today.
To the Ruffians.
Not with the Ruffians.
Unless, Ruffians, you're the same too.
Maybe you have the same confession.
Hopefully not.
Well, Ruffians I think are better than not.
We have something to divulge.
To get off our chest.
Collective chest.
Do you know what it is, Ruffians?
Probably not.
If you knew what it is, then Ruffians, you probably are the same as us right now.
It's this.
That's not us, but it is us.
We haven't slept yet since we all had so much fun playing River City Girls.
But it's okay though because we're feeling good and most importantly we got a lot of homework done!
You know we can have lots more fun together because we got it done.
It's not like we're putting it off or anything.
No, no.
It wasn't that.
It was just, you know, you want to do it, but then you just can't.
Yeah, like there's a lot of things going on and it just never really happens.
Yeah.
You mean to, but it's just like... It got away from me.
So, we finally got it!
Almost, almost all done.
We've been able to focus pretty well too, right Moco-chan?
It's good.
Because you know sometimes when you don't sleep, you think, I'm gonna get it all done!
It'll be good!
I have so much time!
As you go along, it's just like... The train is stopping.
No!
We're still good!
And maybe Ruffians, maybe you can tell a little bit, but actually we get a little silly when we don't sleep for a little while.
So hopefully we're not too crazy today.
It'll be good.
It'll make the Piko Park collab even better.
Ruffians, it's important.
Listen, listen, listen.
Losing clothes.
We know it's not good to do these kinds of things, so we're not gonna make it a habit.
No habits!
So, Ruffians, definitely do not copy us.
Good kids don't follow our bad influences.
Be good, okay?
Be a good Ruffian, okay?
Understood!
Whoops!
No whoops!
What a role model.
Oh, but if you say it like that, then... Well, you know, I didn't sleep.
It was all for your sake.
Oh no.
This ties in with something else, but... Ruffians, you've done it.
You've done it.
BAU BAU.
Moco-chan!
We have to keep things moving, okay?
FUWAMOCO Morning only lasts so many minutes!
We're professionals, right?
Do the Ruffians even care?
We're professionals!
We're on air, Moco-chan!
Oh no.
Are we gonna have to apologize for this later?
Shikkari shite!
Moco-chan!
Shikkari shite yo!
Okay.
A professional smile is all we needed.
Yeah.
Oh.
The next topic.
I guess it's sort of similar to sleeping.
Or not sleeping.
Which one?
But sort of sleeping.
So, you might have seen on Twitter the other day... About Fuwawa.
You know.
So, when we were going to sleep...
We have both been in our beds for around maybe 10 minutes or so?
Maybe 15 minutes.
I was really sleepy.
When I heard Fuwawa take a deep breath, like really really deep, like... That bad?
Yeah, like...
Did you hear my voice?
Like, curvy!
Curvy!
Really, really loud!
It made me jump.
And then... Then you said, I'm just waiting for you to wake up, okay, Moco-chan?
Scary.
Yeah, in sort of like a huffy way.
A huffy way like... Yeah.
So I was really confused because obviously I hadn't even slept yet and it wasn't time to wake up either.
So I tried to let Fuwawa know that
It's not time to wake up yet!
But she didn't like my answer.
It was just all like, well, let me know when you're gonna get up then.
Or something like that.
That mean.
That doesn't sound like me.
No.
When you're sleepy you're mean.
But do you remember any of this?
I don't.
I don't... I remember waking up at one point and checking my clock and being like... It feels like I slept for 12 hours, but it's only been one hour.
That's so weird.
Or maybe not.
It wasn't even one hour.
It was just that my clock when I went to sleep had the big numbers saying... One big numbers?
One set of big numbers?
What does that mean?
I thought it said a big number!
I looked at it again and it changed to another number.
Oh!
So I thought it was one hour.
But it wasn't one hour.
It was probably just like you said, 15 minutes or something.
For what it's worth, I did check the tweet with you to make sure it was okay before I sent it.
But do you remember it?
I remember that.
Kind of.
I remember being a bit grumpy.
And being like, as long as it doesn't make me look bad.
Really?
Thank you, Ruffians!
Do you feel different towards me now?
There's no answer!
Mococo is good!
The Ruffians still love you, it's okay.
It's okay!
I'm glad.
Definitely out of the two of us, Fuwawa sleep talks a lot more.
But it's sort of fun because if you respond to her, you can try to pick her brain while she's sleep talking.
So if you ask things about what she's saying, it's sort of fun.
Usually she'll just get mad because you don't really understand what she's talking about and just keep on asking questions.
Like, what are you doing with the blueberries?
And then she'll be like, Moco-chan, of course I'm doing this with them!
Like, it's my fault for not understanding.
You need to understand all the time, Moco-chan!
Why don't you understand the reality?
That's how the sleep talking goes.
I don't know why, it seems like you talk about blueberries a lot.
I don't know, I just have blue on the brain, huh?
Yeah.
Watch out Ruffians!
Moco-chan!
Moco-chan might get you while you're deep asleep and make you sleep talk to her!
I'll make you sleep talk!
And then I'll tweet about it!
Scary!
Spooky!
You wouldn't want that, right?
Well, Ruffians, it's good that Moco-chan's in a good mood right now.
Because I have something to share with you today.
I don't know.
Someone, just someone, I happen to know.
Ruffians, you happen to know too.
There's been quite a handful recently.
Yes!
That's it!
Moco-chan, it's you!
Moco-chan!
She, she has been something.
Yes, that she is you, Moco-chan.
You've been very needy, and I just can't really deal with it.
You know, Ruffians, I talked about it a bit during River City Girls, but it's gotten even worse since then.
I think you're just exaggerating things.
No.
Moco-chan, she's been really clingy and a bit sulky recently.
You seem sort of happy about it.
No, I'm just informing the Ruffians.
You know, cause I need help.
I need help.
But Moco-chan, she keeps on whining and being like, I wanna spend more time with the Ruffians!
I want to see them now!
Why can't it be now?
That doesn't sound like me at all.
Ruffians are busy, you know?
That's why we have a strict schedule.
So that we can be able to have lots of fun together at the specific times, playing the specific games, doing the specific things, you know?
But she doesn't stop.
She's needy!
She's clingy!
You're just exaggerating, okay?
I can't take it!
I can't take it any longer, Moco-chan!
So, Ruffians, I see there's already a lot of headpats, but please, if you could give her some headpats, maybe tell her it'll be okay.
You know, let her know how much you're looking forward to our streams and how much you're looking forward to be able to chat.
I think that might help Moco-chan calm down a little bit.
And Twitter, too.
Twitter, too?
Yeah.
It would help me a lot, too.
Let's all be kind to Moco-chan, okay?
Always.
Forever.
Every day.
Every minute.
Maybe me, too.
Since I have to deal with this.
Yeah.
It's tough.
Right, Ruffians?
Are there any older Ruffians?
Like older sibling Ruffians out there?
Older Ruffian, you're an older Ruffian.
I'm not an older Ruffian.
You're older.
I'm not an older Ruffian, I'm Fuwawa!
And older.
You just admitted it.
I'm a bit older than you, but... Not ancient, no.
Well, Ruffians!
We wanted to explain something that maybe is a bit of a mystery to you, but I think it's kind of an interesting story, right?
Maybe.
I wanna ask you a simple color- uh, question.
A simple question.
Don't laugh, Moco-chan!
A simple question!
About colors.
A simple color about questions.
Understand!
Colors!
Ruffians, what are your favorite colors?
Huh?
Blue!
Thank you!
Red!
I'm sorry about that, Moco-chan.
Orange!
That's Kiara-senpai.
Your favorite colors!
Purple!
Orange!
I'm getting concerned here.
It's a simple question about colors, and I'm not seeing the answers!
Why?! !
Okay, well, I guess I'll just have to give the Ruffians the answer then.
The answer was pink and blue.
Blue and pink.
Yeah.
Wow!
Why?
Why are FUWAMOCO blue and pink?
Why am I blue?
Why is Moco-chan pink?
The Ruffians even deserve the answer.
No one said pink!
I know, I know.
Are you curious?
Well... I guess.
Well...
It's actually really simple.
It's simple.
So you know, Mama Puppy could tell that she was gonna be having twins, and so she thought that she'd need an easy way to tell us apart.
You know, sometimes it can be sort of tough, right?
Right.
Do you know what she did?
Huh?
Wow, she looked at a lot of blue and pink pictures, and also ate a lot of blue and pink seeds.
I was thinking, you know, the first born will be blue, and the second will be pink.
You know, that way... Does it count as image training?
Image training, that's exactly it.
But you know, that way, we're color-coded, and it'll be easy to know who's who, right?
Right.
Yeah.
Of course.
I see.
Why shaved ice though?
Because it's yummy.
Yeah, you know, that's just what Mama Puppy wanted to eat.
Yeah, yeah.
Of course you eat other nutrition foods though.
Nutrition.
Just shaved ice.
Vitamins.
Yeah, it was a lot of pink and blue shaved ice, but never mixed together!
No.
It was always separate.
Blue shaved ice and pink shaved ice.
No purple.
Yeah, that would be confusing.
That would be a problem.
Yeah.
So, you know when we were born and my eyes were pink?
And blue.
Yeah, Moco-chan's a blue.
You know, she was really relieved, right?
The wise puppies, they were right!
That's why they're wise.
Yeah, that's why they're wise.
And you know, now it'd be easy to tell us apart!
Yeah!
Right?
It came true.
Good story.
Meditash, meditash.
Maybe this is a weird question, but don't you feel like if you were in Mama Puppy's place, that that would be your biggest concern too?
A big concern.
For us, you know, ever since we can remember, I've been blue, and Moco-chan, you've been pink!
Yeah, not red.
No, not red.
No, not red, not red.
Pink, pink.
And if it's switched, you know, it just doesn't really feel right.
Ten times worse than being pet backwards against your fluff.
With a face.
Not good.
Ruffians or siblings, do you have a similar story?
Any colloquial stories?
I wonder.
You know?
Invincibles!
I'm glad.
Fuwawa is pink and Moco-chan is blue.
No!
That's wrong!
You like pink better now.
I see some Ruffians saying they like pink better now.
Maybe Ruffians will think of Mama Puppy when they eat pink shaved ice and blue shaved ice?
Not together.
That's a little weird.
Please don't think of Mama Puppy, okay?
True, true.
Think about Moco-chan or me.
Yeah.
Please, please, please.
Thank you!
And we have some more happy news!
Ruffians!
The FUWAMOCO Morning Jingle!
There are only two days left to submit your FUWAMOCO Morning Jingle.
I think a lot of Ruffians have made jingles.
But there's still lots more coming in two weeks!
Amazing.
You don't need a reminder though, do you?
Thank you Ruffians for your amazing submissions!
At first, actually, we were really worried that you might not be that interested in it.
So, we really want to say a big thank you for being brave and doing a lot of research into trying new things.
You know, what it takes to make a jingle, make your first piece of music, you know.
We love them so much!
Thank you!
You know what?
It actually gives us a lot of courage to try new things too.
Thank you!
Next week, we're going to be showcasing some submissions and then announcing the selected jingle exactly one week today on September 8th, Friday.
The Friday FUWAMOCO Morning.
We hope that you'll be looking forward to it!
It'll be another chapter of FUWAMOCO Morning history made all together.
More history.
I wonder what kind of historic moments we have in FUWAMOCO Morning.
I can't think of any.
Everyone's favorite.
Everyone's favorite!
It's the Doggie of the Day!
And who do we have?
Today's doggy is... Den!
It's Moniac!
Moniac!
Moniac, she's a small troublemaker, but I'm sure she's an even bigger friend.
Do we look the same?
Morning!
I don't think you should be shy.
You're BAU-tiful no matter what kind of face you're making.
No mood.
Just show your BAU-ty.
BAU-ty.
I was kind of confused if you were saying BAU-ty.
That was an attempt already.
How does Morniac BAU BAU?
I like to think maybe it's like a spiky... Like a BAU!
BAU!
Oh, I think it's a bit more like BAU!
Oh, really?
Like a muted... Not muted, just short.
A short BAU BAU.
Because Morniac's a small troublemaker?
No, I just have that feeling.
Okay.
I think, you know, Morning likes to make mischief.
Like us.
Make funny faces.
Us too.
A little shy.
I get it.
Great friend!
She's such a good girl.
Great friend with great face.
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
Thank you for the food!
You get a treat now.
Yeah, yeah.
BAU BAU!
Today I went on a walk.
Where did we go?
This Ruffian went for a walk.
Is that a painting?
It looks like a painting.
Such a pretty water river.
It's a beautiful photo!
We're so happy to hear that you're out enjoying the sights while on your way home.
You're way home!
Wow.
You know, sometimes you can kind of get wrapped up in your thoughts after a busy day and just end up tuning everything else.
But look around!
There's so much beautiful stuff to look at!
Right!
And that's why I'm so glad that you took a detour out of your usual path just to take this photo for us!
Just for us!
We're lucky, Moco-chan.
Actually, you know, we like to do the same thing too, you know?
Even just on like a little walk, we try to take at least one photo to kind of make it a bit special.
Make a memory of it.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, and there's boarding!
Boarding goes on here too, like little boats.
I don't know, maybe next time, instead of taking a walk, you could give kayaking a try!
Can you kayak there?
Oh!
I don't know, but baby kayaking is kind of a big step.
It's a bit scary.
First swimming, then kayaking.
BAU BAU!
And next we have our Question of the Day!
What kind of question do we have?
De-den!
Oh!
You don't eat tomato, don't eat pizza, don't eat pasta, don't eat burgers, don't eat onion, don't eat burrito.
So what exactly do you regularly eat?
What's a normal FUWAMOCO breakfast?
Dinner?
I want to eat your regular meals as well.
Those aren't our meals!
You can't eat them!
We'll share our food with each other, but I don't think there's that much.
What we eat?
I don't know, it's not very interesting.
It's not very interesting.
I know we talked a bit about, I don't know, what we thought was our silly eating habits, but maybe it's not.
Maybe it's not, but in an ideal world, you know, we like to eat Japanese food, Chinese food, Indian or Thai cuisines.
Sushi, sashimi.
And of course, lots of wagashi.
Sweet, sweet!
JAPAN DOPE!
Yeah, yeah.
Milky yum.
But, you know, reality, it's not the same.
So we eat kind of stuff like, you know, chicken, natto.
Natto for me in the morning.
Cucumber.
Aojiru.
Aojiru is like a green veggie drink.
We have that with soy milk.
Soy milk.
We have raw veggies.
Miso soup.
I really like to have nori as a snack, like the seaweed.
Yeah, yeah.
Sometimes almonds, eggs, stuff like that.
And we talked about it before, but cream cheese on unhealthy bread.
Healthy bread.
Yeah.
But generally, you know, simple foods are cost-efficient, have good vitamins, and no chance in it.
We've been pretty busy recently, so we've been keeping things especially simple.
Keep it simple.
Lamb!
That's fancy.
That's so fancy!
That would be yummy though.
But you know, we kinda keep things really simple to the point that everything's more or less the same for months and months.
You know, it wakes us up because we never seem to get tired.
Yeah.
It's good.
You know, for example, one summer, we more or less just ate our own special recipe for Japanese hiyashi-chuka, like summer cold noodles.
Not hayashi-chuka.
It's okay!
Yeah.
Yeah, hiyashi-chuka.
But, you know, it would be nice to have some special yummies again someday soon, but...
It's okay, you know.
I think in the end we're just very picky, maybe weird, maybe particular eaters in general.
But we like a lot of food.
We just don't like those foods with pasta and onions and tomatoes and stuff.
Ruffians, are you the same?
Same!
You understood, understood.
Tasty thing.
Poor puppies.
No, no, no.
It's okay.
Fussy puppy maybe.
Maybe we're fluffy fussy.
Poor Pero.
Fluffy fussy.
Fuzzy.
Fussy fussy.
No onions?
Of course no onions.
No, no, no.
I don't want to even be around an onion.
No, thank you.
It's worse when they're there.
What's it?
Sautéed.
Ah, the flavor comes out.
The smell.
The smell is awful.
No.
Uh-uh.
It tastes like worms.
Sorry, I can't be around an onion.
No.
Uh-uh.
Garlic?
Garlic is questionable.
Uh-uh.
It's questionable.
We're not friends.
No.
Yeah.
Understood.
I'd say it's like a 25% eat.
What?
Garlic.
Oh, garlic?
Yeah.
Maybe.
Poor Aqua-senpai.
I'm sorry.
Purple onions are the worst actually.
BAU BAU!
And for our next stream, we have...
Pico-Pike!
Yes!
We are playing Pico-Pike together with Abyssgard!
I'm really looking forward to it, but I think it's going to be really, really crazy.
Especially because Moco-chan and I are going to be sharing the controller!
I don't know how.
I'm not sure.
We will fight!
Fight!
Rock, paper, scissors?
Rock, paper, scissors.
Maybe.
We'll do our best to make Abyss strong all together.
BAU BAU!
And our schedule.
And our schedule before it updates to next week's schedule.
Where, well, I think this weekend's maybe a little bit more relaxed for us, but we'll still be having lots of fun.
We're starting out our journey in It Takes Two.
It's actually, it's going to be our first time playing it.
I don't know anything.
We're really looking forward to it.
You know, it's a classic.
A classic.
Lots of Ruffians want to see it, so.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm excited for you.
Sunday, we're going to be doing an extended Super Chat meeting.
Yeah!
You're really excited, Moco-chan.
I am!
It's going to be starting early, and then we'll be going very, very, very late if needed.
Yeah, we might get a little crazy with how long we might go.
At the very least, I think we can say right now it'll be our longest stream yet.
So, Ruffians, please make sure to get very cozy along with us, okay?
BAU BAU!
Well, Ruffians, before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Viewers today!
Happy Friday to you.
Oh, Lime!
Lima!
Lima, sorry!
Lima, BAU BAU!
Momo, BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO BAU BAU!
Coffee!
BAU BAU!
Yuppa!
Hyuka!
BAU BAU!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!